halim messika bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation que ce matin
sur rtl france alors selon les premières
projections le disait le likoud arrive
donc en tête de ces élections
législatives on va y présenter à ce
scrutin comme une opposition entre pro
et anti netanyahu le premier ministre a
donc pas souffert de son implication
dans des dossiers de corruption
visiblement le public israélien encore
une fois dit son mot comme on dit ici en
israël
c'est dire qu'il a dit ban ou même
natanyahou on veut l'année vous qui
continue à diriger le pays parce que
c'est vrai que l'année dernière et les
deux dernières années il ya eu quand
même si cette extraordinaire qui sont
passés comme bien entendu la résolution
partielle de la critique au vide avec
les arrivées à temps qui nous permettent
nous aujourd'hui de revenir à la vie et
au sourire on va dire il ya eu
effectivement des accords d'abraham avec
quatre pays arabes qui veut joint à la
diplomatie italienne
c'est un
des choses extraordinaires il ya eu à
redonner sens à tout ça a fait la
tanière où il n'a pas trop subi
le problème par rapport à famille il en
demeure pas moins qu aujourd'hui on est
à 31
le revenu par les 80% vote ont été
dépouillés et le likoud est crédité de
30 à 30 30 30 sièges sur l'écran pour
pour former un gouvernement il faut une
majorité de 61 sièges sur 120 au
parlement
est-ce que l'on devra assister
maintenant à des alliances
absolument il ya la grande syrie via
plusieurs grandes surprises en sélection
la première entreprise non retour des
sionistes religieux de vestes à l'aise
et l'autriche qui avait été
cannibalisées par par un des candidats
qui s'appelle pénet aujourd'hui et
qu'ils ont dû revenir sur la scène donc
ils ont sept six ou sept suisses ces
surprises incroyables la chasse aussi
qui a fait une campagne extraordinaire
surtout auprès des molines français donc
des gens qui viennent de france et
disent qu'ils ont dépassé de leurs noces
de chêne il est croyez-moi les
dirigeants des autres partis ils vont
prendre de la graine
et l'on apprend effectivement peut-être
que ses deux sièges supplémentaires
qu'ils ôtent c'est grâce justement à ces
à ces français là il ya une troisième
grande surprise c'est effectivement le
retour aussi de abda qui est le grand
parti de gauche qui étaient solides de
bengo yonne et qui était arrivé
quasiment à zéro qui est maintenant
refait surface
vous avez les partis religieux qui ont
vraiment fait un effort extraordinaire
qui maintenant aujourd'hui son mari
quasiment à 18 19 sièges ce qui est
incroyable plus les parties du par les
sionistes religieux 10 ans quasiment à
32 tous ensemble qui
absolument incroyable contre une
redistribution complète des cartes
aujourd'hui le d'israël je pense
qu'effectivement il va y avoir toujours
avoir un petit problème reste au
gouvernement
là il a un potentiel de voix suffisant
un potentiel mandat suffisant pour
qu'ils puissent monter une coalition de
droite comme c'est comme quand une
personne saine la défense relativement
forte maintenant alors je lui parle que
le même gouvernement stable de droite
avec miami notamment à sa tête si
effectivement des nets de fait trop
appuyé fait pas trop de problèmes à des
nets étant le responsable d'un parti au
pays mena et donc on atteint
effectivement le début des négociations
sinon si jamais on n'a pas de majorité
si les demandes sont trop importantes de
la part de tous ces petits partis ben on
repartira vers une cinquième élection
qui devrait avoir lieu le 21 ça va
passer mais c'est comme ça que ça s'est
produit
comment est ce que vous vous expliquez
vous comprenez cette percée des
suprémacistes blancs
je comprends pas d'avoir le mot
je pense que c'est un mot qui peut-être
correspond aux états unis en israël ça
veut rien dire les suprémacistes blancs
puisque dans tous les partis il ya des
blancs des rouges des verts des noirs et
et c'est donc à pas de régulières dans
la presse oui mais c'est franchement
n'importe quoi ça
ça veut rien dire ici ce qui est
important par contre c'est de voir
effectivement que le pays aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'il est très très divisés
mais aujourd'hui grâce justement à cette
nouvelle élection ou en train de voir
que le parc le pays
image majoritairement de droite si on
additionnait tous les laits toutes les
voix qui ont été données à la droite y
compris cette double donc ça qui est
aussi ses progrès ont quitté on peut
commander des matériaux qui s'est
effondrée ces notes des autres surprises
de ce scrutin
eh ben on voit que le pays quasiment 70
% à droite et s'il n'y avait pas
effectivement des problèmes bigot contre
tous ces gens là on aurait un grand
parti de droite ni terre quel que soit
son groupe qui serait quasiment à 70
c'est à dire 80 81 sièges au parlement
et sa mère ce qui est tout à fait c'est
effectivement la suprématie
départementale blanche c'est la
suprématie des certaine manière les
résultats attendus pour après demain on
suivra ça de près en tout cas sûr été
france merci à vous halim messika
d'avoir répondu à nos questions dans la
matinale de rtl france